and what's cool about this is something
you can see on this drawing on this
sketch is that you could equally say oh
I might be interested in that point done
it how do I find that and you'd have the
difference here and then you'd have to
solve that guy right which would be very
similar to the way that we just
approached this suppose the question was
don't just like maybe you know don't
just find me the the root don't just
find the x-intercept I want you to find
with that like he's he's a stationary
point finally that stationary point is
right so what we would need to do is we
were different she had this thing I
would say what f dash X is gonna be
what's that to e to the 2x minus e DX
that's it and then I have to solve this
thing I would say stationary points
exists when that guy right equals zero
you can see how all these pieces always
combine together right so now you've got
to e to the 2x minus e to the x equals
zero and then you would go off and you
would try to you know manipulate this in
such a way to make it look like a
problem you do know how to solve which I
don't know if that's a good to go bad
thing we are we're trying to in fact one
of the reasons why I thought is worth
pursuing we're trying to show you many
of the like foundations you've laid like
he's we're gonna build a house over here
we're gonna build a house over here
people to have it's like actually this
is all just one big castle they all fit
together yeah yeah we absolutely have
okay yeah you talk about this guy you
just solve it it's easier than it looks
I promise it Daniel
okay yeah it's I promise it's easier
than it looks look you do here
I'm sorry but like my brains yummy help
yeah yeah that's fine so what I'm gonna
do is remember and admittedly like he's
one of the things right I don't mean to
sound weird but one of the things that
happens when you get lots and lots of
practice and develop what's a skill when
you become expert one of the things that
makes an expert an expert is that they
can see past superficial information and
you can see it's almost like wearing
x-ray glasses you can see immediately -
what's the the deep structure that
actually matters here right now when I
look at this it's it's it comes to
practice right every everyone's like
this like what I love I used to be a
touch football coach right really
yeah at my old school I only stopped
because he sport is at the same time as
the exact meeting so I'm like and that
made me really sad part a small part of
my soul to buy it anyway the reason I'm
Highline that is one of the things that
amazed me was here's what would happen
in a normal game okay
normal game we'd turn up to play and
then you know they're coaching my coach
would meet up and we'd say okay well
who's gonna you're gonna ref this game
right it's not like a final it's just
you and me here so generally I would
referee one half and they would referee
the other in a small number of cases the
other coach was like you know a
substitute teacher they're like I don't
know any the rules you can rip the whole
thing right but usually we take turns
right and what would happen is you know
say for example it was you and me that's
coaches right so you would referee the
first half and then I would referee the
second half right now what would happen
is I would actually just for the sake of
illustration let's just reverse it right
so suppose I started off on the field
and we're all playing and then you know
the game proceeds for like 20 minutes
bill goes whistle goes and then and then
you come on and you take over right now
what would happen is I would be standing
on the sidelines with my team because
you are now referee right and you know
all the subs who are on the on the bench
with me right there like shouting all of
these things to the plays on the field
they're like go go to the left or like
there's a gap over here look like this
shouting trying to give them tips right
and they would be mystified as to why
they're you know peers on the field
cannot see what they can see for
off the field and if you ever played a
spot like this you probably know it's
like when you're in yeah when you're in
the thick of it you're like I can't see
anything that ability to be in the
middle of it but also sort of take this
bigger perspective is a skill that comes
with like years of practice right and I
just love like they were a few
particular players I watched and I
remember the captain of the team once
when we won the premiership u12 player
brilliant guy and he just he could do
two things no Mon he could see he just I
don't know like he could watch like and
there wouldn't be a big gap just be like
a little bit of a gap and you can see
okay that's where we gonna head right i
partly don't know the answer and then in
addition to that no no he did it so
consistently I was like this is not a
coincidence you know this is this is a
gift and a skill you've developed over
time and in addition that he just had
this mean dummy past like it was so
convincing everyone got fooled by it and
because you combine those two things
together
he just ran rings around people right
but it's like there's no shortcut to
that I remember saying to him once I was
like I need to like he's graduating
right I'm like you're really good at
throwing a Dom parser see it's how do
you do this and he's like you just have
to do it tens of thousands of times
oh yeah yeah he just been played for a
long time anyway so so I am in that
position for this kind of thing yeah he
has a perspective on it that's like I
can see what's going on right
so in this case thankfully it's
something less philosophically involved
right see that see that e to the 2x
right what my brain is doing is saying
oh what that really is is e to the X
square because of index laws that X I
don't know I did that so fat that X and
that too they really just multiplied
together to give to X right okay
so if that's equal to e to the X can you
see I can just divide both sides by e to
the X do you see that I just divided by
exactly right see this this e to the x
squared up here is just e to the x times
e to the X so therefore one of them is
going to just cancel right and then of
course on the right hand side you can so
I just get one right so I told you it
was easier that it looks right this is 2
e to the x equals 1 e to the x equals
1/2 so this is x equals log of 1/2 now
you might think wait a second I actually
we saw this before right I actually saw
it say it's a negative value over here
that's where the stationary point is but
I've got log of 1/2 which is much
positive except it's not the log of 1/2
is actually log of 2 to the negative 1
do you agree with that you see that 1/2
yes is to the power negative 1 so that's
actually that negative 1 here that
actually can come out the front I've
been I've done this like 3 or 4 times
today right that power jumps out the
front so it's actually negative log 2
and if you don't believe me let's go
back over to our graph and if I put in
negative log 2 BAM negative 0.693 oh
yeah